good morning John I woke up this morning
and it leisurely 10:00 a.m. Eastern Time
and though that is 8 o'clock in the
morning Montana time and that is
somewhat early I am NOT going to
complain no no why it always seems like
thousand places are I start out with us
being unhappy to get out of bed I
brushed my teeth I took a shower and
then I went for a ride on a bike ride or
a car ride or a go-kart ride or a
rollercoaster ride none of those rides
the original ride unless you count
piggyback rides horseback riding why is
it called piggyback riding I'm not a
piggy
everyone knows the answer this question
tell me I was actually unable to confirm
whether people wrote donkeys or horses
first but I'm gonna go ahead and be
amazed either way I'm sitting up there
on this horse named jewel she's not a
big horse she's a very tame horse no
something along the way spooked her and
man that was scary first we're just
doing the thing and I'm all happy and
then the next second and luckily I did
not on my camera in my hand for this
she's just like straight into another
horse which frankly I'm glad off I'm
glad she ran into another horse instead
of off a cliff or just kept going
forever it was like the third time in my
life I've been horseback riding it kind
of scary but this is a very tame very
well behaved force and I've got this
like magnificent contraption that my
Buddism that's designed specifically for
making your butt feel good and my butt
does not feel good nothing feels good my
legs hurt my knees hurt my hips hurt my
butt hurts my back hurts let's just go
ahead and say that give or take 90% of
my things were hurting but an
interesting thing about the
domestication of horses it probably only
happened once there was a first time it
did not arise separately across the
globe there was one place where one
person got on a horse and was like this
is good and it was good it was so good
that a thousand years after the first
person got on a horse and it pretty much
spread everywhere it could spread but it
probably wasn't some dude with a
Deathwish hopped up on wild mushrooms
running out of course the horse pasture
trying to catch a horse and jumping on
it and being like I'm a horse rider
probably not horses were originally
domesticated like almost all animals
except for dogs and cats ah for food but
horses have a very complicated social
structure so you killed their mom and
dad for food and you're raising up the
foal and horses put people into their
complicated social structure and they
will put you in fact at the top of their
hierarchy and this is an excellent
characteristic if you want to
domesticate an animal because then
you're the boss
so that is probably how it happened it
might even have been a young woman
because everyone knows that young boys
don't get obsessed with ponies ever no
now doesn't happen so once that social
bond had been formed the idea of jumping
on one of them and becoming some kind of
super beast didn't seem quite so crazy
and though it may not have been insane
and death-defying it was a very big deal
in the history of our species before
4000 BC all work done for humans was
done by humans figuring out how oxen and
horses and donkeys and other beasts of
burden could pull things and carry
things and carry you was a gigantic leap
forward gigantic on the order of the
Industrial Revolution or the Internet
huge big big change in the way that
people could do things in the way that
people did work in the way that people
moved from place to place in the way the
people fought wars suddenly you could
kind of be a 10 foot tall man with four
feet and amazing balance that could run
50 miles per hour and carry thousands of
pounds this is a gigantic change and for
people who love horses it's also a
beautiful change and sitting up on top
of jewel I can feel a little bit of that
I can feel that she's a wonderful animal
and then she trusts me the relationship
between horse lovers and horses is a
different kind of relationship than I
think that I've ever had it's clearly
amazing and I feel like it's bred both
under the horses and the horse lovers of
genes it's certainly bred the horses
genes that's what domestication is but I
think it's pretty ridiculous to sit back
and think that we've changed the horse
so much without realizing that they've
changed us an awful lot too and John I
can't help but say it I'm more a horse
I'll see you on Wednesday